on est noir de peau certains ne me ne
supporte pas parce que nous sommes noirs
on va pas on va pas leur dire oui
d'accord on ferme le boucher puis on se
tourne non non c'est pas comme ça on a
grandi ici aussi on a grandi à l'école
de la république
on veut la liberté et l'égalité comme
tout le monde je le dis les dragons
si les plus grands chasseurs des skins
de paris
[Musique]
dans les descentes
oui on était là à laisser des plumes
à l'époque mon nom d'essence dans le
quartier latin cinquante et une
soixantaine il y avait le stress en ce
moment il ya le stress il ya tout ça il
ya plein de choses dit un mot des
moments je suis dans les régions
qu'est-ce que je fais là qu est ce que
je la kiffe et que donc penser mes
parents tu me pose plein de questions
et après quand on arrive on ne
s'attendait pas à avoir autant de ce
qu'ils ont en face ils ont des poings
américains des battes de base-ball de la
cie de la cites
oui dès ma première descente j'ai vu de
l'acide
j'ai un ami qui a reçu donc un liquide
sur son blouson son blouson fondé son
bombers sont fondées et à la bagarre qui
se fait des flics arrivent on se sauve
tous que ce soit les skins nous on se
sauve on se disperse ongles mais on
s'est battu qu'est ce que j'ai aimé ça
qu'est ce que j'ai aimé ça c'était
vraiment c'était
je me suis mis l'un des gars parce que
j'étais outrée de voir toute cette chose
à toutes ces choses et ces personnes qui
est prise et les coutumes tu passes
qualité macao où il ya un pas que ça
dans les années quatre des graffitis la
bière en attendant les ratonnades
nocturne pour vous garantir que à cette
époque là vous marchez pas dans les
métros vous marchez pas la défense vous
marchez pas dans la rue c'est pas
possible parce qu'on allait on était
apeuré et en plus c'était comme des
milices et les skinheads à cette époque
là il prenait des voitures trois quatre
voitures et se balader dans les
quartiers il attendait tomber sur des
gens des noirs des arabes pour leur vie
pour les agresser ça tapait quoi donc
il y avait une vraie chasse à l'homme de
leur côté et déjà ont souffert oui mais
ont souffert et c'est pour ça qu'on a
été qu'on a existé
vous allez bon aller porter plainte au
commissariat c'est ça reste étant assez
ensuite quoi donc un parti d'un moment
il fallait bien que quelqu'un se
retrousse les manches des dernières
décembre il fallait de rer
quand vous attendez de rer
c'est que débattent avec plus de 1000
personnes
franchement si vous êtes sans ce qui
n'était même pas sur vos pots y avait
une personne quitte un chef d'un parce
que des skins est aussi qu'avec vous
aussi c'était comme ça déclare aux siens
et je trouve que juré jeune héros penan
a opéré un qui voulait pas lâcher l
saint lazare ne voulait pas lâcher saint
nazaire et tous les jours ou littéraire
un soir je dis ben écoutez frérot moi
moi vos asie rentrée défense moi je moi
je rende pas et vos mecs je les pistes
est pisté piste juste relâché on va
rapporter les rentrées moi je me suis
posé je dormais dans les esprits
toute la nuit j'ai dormi dans ce cahier
j'ai attendu
[Musique]